نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي محادثات في
بيجين مع الرئيس الصيني في جيم بنجا
تناولت الشراكه الاستراتيجيه والحرب في
اوكرانيا وقالت ارسال علمي الصينيه ان
الرئيس شيجينج اعرب لميد زدف عن امنه في
ان تتحلى كل من موسكو وكيف بضبط النفس وان
تعالج اطراف الحرب في اوكرانيا بمخاوفها
الامنيه بالطرق الدبلوماسيه
ان تطوير الشركات الاستراتيجيه بين الصين
وروسيا خيار استراتيجيون طويل يقوم به
البلدان وفقا لظروفهم الوطنيه من جهه
اعلنبي ان محادثاته مع الرئيس الصيني كانت
بناءها ومثمره
لسه لسه
محادثات مع الامين العام للحزب الشيوعي
الصيني والرئيس الصيني ناقشنا خلالها
مجالات التعاون بين الحزبين الحاكمين في
روسيا والصين كما بحثنا التعاون الثنائيه
في اطار شركاتنا الاستراتيجيه في جميع
المجالات بما في ذلك الاقتصاد والانتاج
الصناعي نقشنا ايضا القضايا الدوليه
وتحديدا الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت المحادثات
مفيده للغايه